yo bullet cam i got jason cash
carson is in here man listen we about to
do something crazy right now let's get
to it
yeah and first give an honor to god to
my dad and my mom without them i
wouldn't be on
now that we got that out the way [ __ ]
get this [ __ ] going and make me smile
when they tell you that they next cuz
these [ __ ] ain't even knowing
look drop two records and they both
pressure my only worry for other rappers
[ __ ] do better i was in my cousin lynn
closet for a new sweater
now the only thing they had me down is
that check [ __ ] yeah
made a half a ticket without a college
degree my daughter half of a year but
she'll have it better than me
i wrote this whole verse while putting
carter to sleep i'll be damned rapper
tell you he working harder than me
that's hard to believe
out the mud and still clean that's hard
to achieve and cry till it's over ain't
switching my team
i got these anr's mad cause they know
they shouldn't pass but they didn't
believe
i came too far to fail i'm too fly to
flop i'm too
cool for school [ __ ] just really not
that good there's nothing you can say to
convince me but go on and take a crack
at it
like you bobby and whitney i came from
christ in my city ain't on the map like
i should be i say it over and over so
[ __ ] don't overlook me
[ __ ] gon overbook me [ __ ] don't
overpay me how i ain't never been lazy
[ __ ] i look like tracy mcgrady i'm more
kobe than anything
got him next to the rolly my [ __ ]
sitting clean don't let the cute face
fool you baby i been through things but
what i go through
i grow through as a young and i knew
that i could be anything
and i'm him and there's more to the
story all i know right now
and go play priority hold on [ __ ]
there's more to the story
all i know is out now [ __ ] go play
priority it's featuring blaster jason
catcher did like
300 000 streams like in two days or
something like that you know what i mean
you know it's it's it's major shout out
to one of the carson greats right here
jc
cash yeah yeah